- You're playing Wednesday.
- I am.
- What did you like about
playing that character,
other than you get to be
a little snotty teenager,
I liked it.
- Besides really my middle school years.
What didn't I like?
I was always the biggest
fan of the Addams Family.
I grew up with the movie.
That was always the big
one that I grew up with,
and my mom would always show
me the reruns of the TV show,
which was always a really
silly and fun thing to watch.
But once I passed my middle school years,
I really thought that
the ship had kinda sailed
on me playing a middle schooler.
But when this came
around, it was animation,
I finally had the luck of being
able to take a whack at it.
And she was such a fun character
to try and fill the shoes
of of so many people
that have really killed
it, so I felt really lucky.
- She seems sarcastic, I'm in.
- She is, she's a little bit,
I kind of played her off of
Hannibal Lecter a little bit.
- [Kelly] Love.
- So she's a little bit
of a serial killer vibe,
but in a little girl's body.
- [Kelly] See now,
I did watch that movie.
- Oh, you saw
"Silence of the Lambs?"
- That movie I'm okay with.
Yeah, it's weird.
I just want it to be.
- I don't know why
you're okay with that one.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
It's sir Anthony Hopkins.
- It's terrifying.
- It is,
but somehow he made--
- When he's wearing
the human skin coat
and he's like, "Hello."
- I know, but wait, somehow
he made it charismatic.
I don't know.
(audience laughing)
- The cannibal?
- [Kelly] I know.
- I'm just gonna say we might
have some personal issues.
- I'm all weird.
I know, I know I do.
I probably do, I do.
I thought, I don't know, I find
Anthony Hopkins charismatic.